♪ ♪
>> Tucker: ALL PUBLICIST HAVE
THE SAME STRATEGY.
FIRST YOU DO 60 MINUTES WHEN YOU
ARE SELLING A BOOK, AND THEN YOU
GO ON THE VIEW TO SAY WHAT YOU
SAID ON "60 MINUTES."
USE ALL THAT HAPPENED WITH THE
FORMER FBI DIRECTOR AND NOW, YOU
ARE WATCHING WITH THE DEPUTY, 6I
ARE WATCHING WITH THE DEPUTY, 6U
ARE WATCHING WITH THE DEPUTY, 6E
ARE WATCHING WITH THE DEPUTY, 6S
ARE WATCHING WITH THE DEPUTY, 6A
ARE WATCHING WITH THE DEPUTY, 6D
ARE WATCHING WITH THE DEPUTY, 6E
ARE WATCHING WITH THE DEPUTY, 6W
ARE WATCHING WITH THE DEPUTY, 6M
ARE WATCHING WITH THE DEPUTY, 6C
ARE WATCHING WITH THE DEPUTY, 6B
ARE WATCHING WITH THE DEPUTY, 6,
ARE WATCHING WITH THE DEPUTY, 6A
ARE WATCHING WITH THE DEPUTY, 6D
NOW, TAKING A VICTORY LAP
AROUND MEDIA LANDSCAPE AND
PREDICTABLY HE WAS ON THE
VIEW TODAY TO JUSTIFY DOJ
PLAN TO SPY ON, UNDERMINE AND
PERHAPS OVERTHROW THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES.
HERE IS PART OF IT.
>> YOU UNDERSTAND HOW FAR WE
HAVE BEEN PUSHED EVEN TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION THAT INCLUDED THOSE
STATEMENTS.
WE WERE ALL OPERATING UNDER
INCREDIBLE STRESS.
WE WERE ALL GRAPPLING WITH THIS
IDEA THAT WE HAVE A PRESIDENT
WHO WE THINK MAY HAVE COMMITTED
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE.
WHO WE THINK MAY IN FACT BE A
THREAT TO NATIONAL SECURITY.
WHAT DO WE DO IN THIS
CIRCUMSTANCE?
>> Tucker: RUSSIA, ONE MAN WHO
LIKES THE SOUND OF THAT I DID
UNIVERSITY LAW PROFESSOR AND
DUMPSTER FIRE RICHARD PAINTER,
ENDORSE THE IDEA TO REMOVE THE
PRESIDENT.
RICHARD PAINTER JOINS US NOW,
RICHARD THANK YOU FOR COMING ON
AND GO TO SEE YOU TONIGHT.
HOW WOULD THIS EXACTLY WORK?
OBVIOUSLY, NEVER ATTEMPTED TO.
THIS IS NOT THE KIND OF SCENARIO
DESIGN FOR, BUT IN YOUR MIND,
HOW WOULD THEY REMOVE THE
PRESIDENT, BY FORCE, WITH
FIREARMS, NASA, HOW WOULD THIS
PLAY OUT TECHNICALLY SPEAKING?
>> Richard: FIRST, WE ARE IN A
GREAT TIME AND I LOVE THE
UNIVERSITY OF MINNESOTA THERE.
BUT I'VE TALKED ABOUT THE 25TH
AMENDMENT AND NUMBER OF TIMES.
BUT WITH RESPECT TO THE
PRESIDENT, THE CONSTITUTION IN
THE LATE 1960s TO ADDRESS THE
SITUATION IN WHICH THE PRESIDENT
IS PHYSICALLY OR MENTALLY
INCAPACITATED AND UNABLE TO
CARRY OUT HIS DUTIES.
>> Tucker: RIGHTS, WE KNOW
WHAT IT IS.
BUT HOW WOULD YOU AFFECT THAT?
HOW WOULD YOU DO THAT?
THE PRESIDENT WOULD CONCEDE TO
BEING OVERTHROWN, SO WOULD YOU
RUSH INTO HIS OFFICE?
WOULD YOU ROUSE HIM FROM BED?
HOW WOULD YOU DO THIS?
>> Richard: TO OVERTHROW THE
PRESIDENT, THIS IS NOT ABOUT
OVERTHROWING THE PRESIDENT.
THERE ARE THOUSANDS OF
PSYCHIATRISTS WHO HAVE VOICED
EXTREME CONCERNS ABOUT
PRESIDENT TRUMP --
>> Tucker: I'VE GOT IT, YOU
HAVE STRENGTHS TO AGREE HE
SHOULDN'T BE PRESIDENT AND 99%
OF THEM I'M SURE YOU WOULD GET
TO SAY THAT.
>> Richard: THE 25TH
AMENDMENT, THE CABINET, THE
MAJORITY OF THE CABINET AND THE
VICE PRESIDENT COULD TEMPORARY
REMOVE THE PRESIDENT FROM
OFFICE.
>> Tucker: BUT HOW DO THEY DO
THAT?
I HAVE READ THE AMENDMENT.
>> Richard: THEY WANT TO
REMOVE HIM.
THAT IS NOT WHAT IS PROVIDED FOR
THE CONSTITUTION.
TO REMOVE HIM FROM OFFICE BUT
THE OBJECTIVE OF THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
TO TAKE OVER THE DUTIES OF THE
PRESIDENT TEMPORARILY WHILE THE
PRESIDENT FOR EXAMPLE IDENTIFY A
PSYCHIATRIC EXAM --
>> Tucker: WASHINGTON, SO YOU
ARE ALWAYS RUSHING AROUND AND
THE PRESIDENT SAYS I'M NOT
CRAZY.
I DON'T WANT TO LEAVE.
I WAS ELECTED BY VOTERS TWO
YEARS AGO AND THEN YOU DO WHAT?
I'M NOT LEAVING.
>> Richard: THE VICE PRESIDENT
TO TEMPORARILY REMOVE THE
PRESIDENT, THEN IT WOULD BE UP
TO TWO-THIRDS OF THE
UNITED STATES HOUSE AND SENATE
TO PERMANENTLY REMOVE THE
PRESIDENT UNDER THE 25TH
AMENDMENT.
>> Tucker: WE ARE OUT OF TIME.
LOOK, THINK THIS THROUGH A
LITTLE BIT.
COME BACK AND WE CAN PLAY IT ALL
OUT BECAUSE YOU JUST STARTED
YOUR OWN --
>> Richard: THE 25TH